I wanted to talk about autumn first
because feature directorial debut is
huge with her photography and music
video background do you notice her
experience in those realms coming
through in her direction here at all oh
yeah big time but my favorite thing is
she's got a specific thing about a rock
star hair on the boys and so she would
just consistently be coming Envy like no
you just you're not doing it right and
just messing with the boys hair to get
it like perfectly rock star Donny
PC boys yeah like PC not wavy or
something she was a PC PC yes when PC
had very polite well yeah I wouldn't
suppose she does stuff like that like
she's not the nice junky yeah she'd come
in and separate our chairs in a certain
way because I think your head's a tiny
bit bigger than mines she wants to
stagger our costumes and world building
like this but I did want to ask you
about something that I was reading in
the press no it's good you described
yourself as a very cosmic person and you
knew instantly when you met her that it
was kind of the right fit so yeah I
don't know what is that feeling like and
if you had that with any other
filmmakers you've worked with yes the
feeling is like you know when you
usually meet somebody you're like hello
how do you do and you exchange all of
these pleasantries there are certain
people that I meet that that just
doesn't happen you just walk into each
other and it's like where have you been
for you know the 23 years I've been on
the planet and let's talk about
everything and then within ten minutes
you're crying and it's it's all very
intense and emotional but yeah also and
I kidnapped each other and we'd have not
really left each other's side since so
much I mean actually speaking of which
aren't you good friends with me as well
yeah you think that that came in handy
with your on-screen relationship here
because they time charming oh thank you
so much yeah we've been preparing for
these roles for four years
but it was so cute talking about cosmic
awesome had this beautiful ornate box
that she had made by hand and had
pictures of all the people she wanted to
cast and she had no idea that me and I
were friends and she just pulled up a
picture of me and said I feel like this
could be your best friend
and I was like yeah literally was on the
phone with her this morning so I'm yeah
having that kind of shorthand really
helps and it just there's a lot of love
in this movie music experience obviously
I am curious what you thought of the
final cut of the film when you actually
heard the whole thing piece together
with the score here this is yeah this is
a huge thing to get you know to to write
the credit song and it was nice to have
been living inside the character for so
long and then get to have his
perspective in the song and it has his
love of Emma kind of pouring out which
is yeah the rhythm in this movie is so
so important is that something you guys
can feel working while you're on set
filming or does that come through moreso
in the Edit process um I think you can
feel it yeah you can you can feel when
everyone's on the same beat if that
makes sense even if you're on a skewed
beat it works like that because every
person that you're acting with is like a
dance partner so you have to adjust to
their rhythm a little bit but I think I
think we're all pretty much in sync
there is I think that Austin's really
musical that the Lions have this sort of
sense of flow and they're very long
complicated sentences sentences so you
wouldn't think I could speak them but
yeah if you don't put that get the
syntax right if you don't have the comma
in the right place it's not going to
hold this word up in the right way and
that's a kind of music and the beats and
the pauses and the missed moments and
things like that that's all what this
world is in terms of the body language
and the way they communicate so it's
it's hugely Musical and all those beats
are really important do you find any
particular line of dialogue kind of
tripping you up and you know this is B
not being an actor but I imagine once
you'd like it if it has a melody kind of
feeling to it once you say something one
way it can be difficult to change just
one single word to kind of fall into
pace with everything else oh yeah but my
I mean I have one for myself which was
imperturbable I struggled to say that a
couple of times yeah
well it's also like an Emma's voice it's
like imperturbable it's like that but um
I'll never forget Mia had never seen the
word
she's before and she just didn't know
what they were and just continuously
being like galoshes galoshes
it was very cute I'm trying to think
there's there's some lines that
Knightley says that are quite famous
like badly done indeed and it was really
hard in the scenes where I had those
lines to kind of just get that out of my
head and just play it as it were and I
actually the that's the the the
wonderful thing about playing scenes
with Anya is there's
she's so present and you know that there
was a strong kind of emotion to those
scenes so you'd say the line and be like
oh I wasn't thinking of so and so saying
that that line yeah so I am upcoming
stuff of course and by the way this is
in the collider team's words not mine
specifically but I quote get your [ __ ]
together and release a new album I'm
working on it I'm working it I am I have
I have a bunch of stuff recorded and I'm
always putting out music just maybe not
in the album form Ivor
so what am i doing I've been in the
studio recording old songs at the moment
in new ways that's like one of the fun
projects that I'm doing kind of
completely reinterpreting old music of
mine so I don't mean to something that
might be a surprise but hearing that
does excite me is it is it new ways like
from from a tech perspective from an
instrument perspective everything well
mostly the instrument perspective and
even the delivery but like raising like
old like 808 drum machines and like
since there's synthesizers and stuff
like that and yeah I could tell you what
it's for but it's it's anyway that's
gonna happen and and I also have a bunch
of new new new songs coming out so you'd
say that Department I will move on and
we can ask you about the thing you've
been hearing about for years now because
I'm a big Josh Boone fan and New Mutants
can't wait yeah one have you seen the
final cut of the movie and to what is it
like leading up to the release of a
movie that you filmed at a different
point in your career um I have seen the
final cut of the movie um which was
really nice cuz josh is really happy
with it and it was just nice to get the
gang all together again and you know
just to because it's felt like this
imaginary friend that you keep telling
people is real but other people haven't
seen it yet now I'm like no I told you
like it's it's a real thing and I don't
really know how to feel about a lot of
things right now I have five movies
coming out this year and I'm just trying
to like eat my vegetables and go to
sleep and take care of him right so we
have one wonderful one to celebrate
thank you